سفينه الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب في بحر لا يهدا ابدا امواجهم
متلاطمه اغرقت حملته للرئاسيه المقبله في
اليقين سفينه ترامب امام جبل جليدي قد
ينهي مسيرته السياسيه هذه المره مثل ما قد
يعيد اليها الزخم من جديد
فالخطر الرئيسي الذي يواجهه يتمثل في
ابتعاد القاعده الناخبه للجمهوريين
المعتدلين والمستقلين عنه
فئه يمكن ان ترى في توجيه التهم اليه امام
المحكمه الجنائيه في نيويورك خطا احمر لا
يمكن تجاوزه في اختيارها لمن سيمثل الحزب
الجمهوري وتوجيه الاتهام هذا يمكن ان يمهد
الطريق امام سلسله متاعب قضائيه اخرى
فالرجل مستهدف ايضا بتحقيق حول اداره
محفوظات البيت الابيض وينتظر قرارا وشيكا
بخصوص ممارسه ضغوط انتخابيه في ولايه
جورجيا غير ان توجيه التهمه يمكن ان يفيد
المرشح الرئاسي الذي لم تستعد حملته حتى
الان الزخم المطلوب فتره بارع في تحويل
الهجمات التي يتعرض لها الى مرتدات يسجل
منها اهدافا لا يتم توقعها معظم استطلاعات
الراي ما زالت تظهر ان الرئيس السابق
سيفوز في الانتخابات التمهيديه للحزب
الجمهوري بفارق كبير وربما هذا ما يفسر
امتناع غالبيه المرشحين المنافسين
للملياردير المثير للجدل في الانتخابات
التمهيديه للجمهوريين عن انتقاده بسبب
متاعبه القضائيه حرصا على عدم اثاره غضب
القاعده الانتخابيه التي قد تكون مفيده في
مساعي الغصول الى البيت الابيض بلال
الوجداني العربيه